in an international study only 40
percent of students correctly solve this
question if a and b are non-zero vectors
and they satisfy the norm of a plus b is
equal to the norm of a minus B then
which option must be true the norm of a
is equal to the norm of B A and B are
parallel vectors A and B are
perpendicular vectors or a plus b is
equal to zero
to work it out we start with the known
condition and then we Square both sides
we convert this to dot products and then
expand
we can now cancel out the norm of a
squared and the norm of B squared on
both sides leaving the following
equation now a dot b is equal to B dot a
so we can simplify this equation bring
all the terms to the left hand side and
divide by 4.
we have a dot b is equal to 0 for
non-zero vectors so the correct answer
is C A and B are perpendicular vectors